Avante Logan has had five abortions and
says she's not ashamed I'm proud of
being able to access abortion I am proud
of the abortions I've had because I
wouldn't be here today
Logan has an 11 year old daughter and no
plans for more children she juggles
motherhood with a job she says she loves
any history of fainting spells or
guiding other women through the abortion
process at whole Women's Health and
abortion clinic in Charlottesville
Virginia it's not just
a person having an abortion it's a
person
speaking up and taking control for the
rest of their life how they saw it and
how they planned it
[Applause]
getting an abortion has been
increasingly difficult in the United
States since June when the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade now six months
later 24 states have banned abortions or
are likely to do so I truly didn't think
that that right would be taken away from
us more than 34 million women of
reproductive age live in states where
abortions are currently banned that's
forced many to travel more than 2 000
miles to reach this Clinic
to pack up and drive across the country
because you know no one will see you
especially in a place like Texas where
it's like 18 hours to get out of the
state or more Stacy Ballentine moved
away from Indiana after the state
legislature passed an abortion ban she
used to work for an abortion clinic
there and would have risked jail time if
she'd stayed now she works at whole
Women's Health in Virginia I mean it's
crazy there's no reason that we can't
help people regardless of where we live
in the midwest Illinois is among the few
states where abortions remain protected
these women with the Chicago abortion
fund work to help women from abortion
ban States travel to Illinois for the
procedure we provide logistical
financial and emotional support So
helping affirm to folks that the the
difficulty for which right now it is to
access abortion is not a reflection of
the morality of their decision I can
also follow up with you via text message
this despite these efforts researchers
estimate There Were Ten Thousand fewer
legal abortions in the U.S in the first
two months after Roe v Wade fell
anti-abortion activists say that's a
significant Victory and have vowed to
pass more abortion restrictions
the battle over abortions is playing out
now in state legislatures and courtrooms
affecting one of the most intimate
decisions of a person's life
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera
Charlottesville Virginia